sa bio j'aimerais qu'on fasse ce soir
qu'on voit qui est le champion des
champions sur trois épreuves aulas ok
première épreuve je me suis pas du tout
entraîné je découvre les épreuves comme
toi
première épreuve c'est la poubelle on va
lancer dans une poubelle et
métiers 1
alors d'accord c'est voulons faire
passer le bac là dessus d'une
deuxième épreuve au plus près du bord
c'est à dire qu'on doit faire glisser
nantais ont fait
goûter 300 euros puis début les
prisons
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une troisième épreuve le bot le bon
flic le battlefield on doit faire voilà
ce qu'explique va prendre la bouteille
sabam et la bouteille oui je le fais
soyez fan de temps je ne le fais jamais
voilà tu as des bouteilles à les voilà
partis elles sont trop plein tu trouves
à te dire tu fais souvent
à lille elles sont un peu trop plein
tarif
patients aïe aïe aïe
[Applaudissements]
le gagnant se pisser lui jamais sa
gueule
sans trois pour le santal et vanille ou
safari
voilà on s'est un peu plus ternes aux
associés au bout de dix on l'a pas fait
celui qui a mis un point qui gagnent
maintenant
attendez avec les bleus
d'ailleurs il ya des bleus là comme ça
tiens ça c'est décidé je trouve qu'ils
ont fait pipi
à ça allait pas mal ça c'est mieux ça
passe est resté aïe aïe aïe c'est une
très belle séquence
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là deux annonces et mentale vas-y
fabiola 2e 3 en fait c'est ça tu vois si
on doit lancer la bouteille au cvo
pousser le plus loin possible sont sans
dépasser
ouais mais pour l'instant il ya un point
partout hockey alliance avec les par
marc webb s'entraîner ou voilà c'est à
droite à droite a entraîné une fois
depuis trois jours
[Applaudissements]
la demande moi c'est l'entraînement et
manipulé s'entraîner alors là suis là
dans la tuerie continent non vraiment
alors tu mènes derrière un dernier
entraînement d'appui allez vous allez
vas-y le terminal et
c'est l'entraînement ça se
fête non non non
[Applaudissements]
c'est des fous alors pierre feuille
ciseaux pouvoir qui pensent à la mairie
si ce retour c'est vrai que c'est toi
qui compte mais c'est pas là c'est moi
qui veux gagner mais qu'elle a le ciseau
coupe la feuille et simao
et prennent en compte sont créés
apprécions
les cinémas du gard
à
0-0 n'inquiète pas c'est pas mal comme
tu es bien fait de venir à jeun la photo
dans la vague mais la photo est belle
hein à moi de commencer à aller
et art et essai musical une hausse
des mois de mousson
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens bien fabio
attention à l'est
[Applaudissements]
et là elle est restée à la loi dans
celle en battant sur la table c'est bon
autrefois qui parlera ici non non non
non non la présentation l'avait sur le
côté on la met sur le côté comme tout à
leur nom et a été mordu aux magouilles
la bordure board maintenant allez allez
vas-y bordure du matériau à toulouse
c'est d'étudier ou surtout fier à
champions champions champions
[Musique]
allait se jouer maintenant ça va bien
aller lâche rien c'est mental mais tu
sais sur les circuits ses toiles au un
ici tu dois faire tes potes fabio
est bon sa bo c'est ce que j'espère
j'espère qu'une chose
c'est que tu me batte l'immense
j'aimerais perdre contre un immense
champion immensément tu veux commencer
tout votre chance il vous endort l'art
comme en mai commence allez ça va se
jouer sur ce point bien entendu si vous
nous rejoignez moi c'est pas mal
est-ce que
eh bien non
et c'est ça qui nous est soudain tout à
l'heure si ses skieurs qui vous a sauvé
quand même mais c'est le basket
et la
politique a déclaré forfait dire j'ai
perdu j'ai perdu c'est un mauvais coup
j'ai peur qu'il est capable de se gêner
ordures j'aimais la musique en plus là
[Rires]
ça a bien marché tout à l'heure la veste
et marche pas pareil quand il a la veste
en mode c'est différent car c'est vrai
c'est comme cela animal
ce matin
[Applaudissements]
à la
gare la non non non non non non
[Applaudissements]
déclare
troisième
jaune ou bleu le jaune
c'est très simple
il est capable d'inventer 72 pour gagner
alors cette épreuve compte double
la mauvaise pour des mares de là il faut
qu'il s'entraîne ce qu'il a jamais allé
moi non plus
[Applaudissements]
alors les mecs deux doigts d'arrêter un
toit c'est juste vois tu vois tu peux
démarrer de la thur fallu alors un peu
plus loin l'abandon reculons que petit à
petit à l'écouter chaussures à la russie
va très bien avec ma veste
atépa maltais pas mal assez fort a les
moyens presque oui bien c'est vrai mais
on n'est pas les mêmes tons et afrique
normalement
ça marche ça convoitant juste pour voir
mais il faut mettre un truc de dans
ses bouteilles d'eau
soit fort recul et maintenant tu sais
quoi regardez
vas-y a commenté loeb d'abord non mais
non combat de plus en plus lourd après
tak tak fait secours locaux vides
[Applaudissements]
west dont les toits de 2 à 6
kms a
[Rires]
juste eu mort mais
moi j'ai jamais
déclarée vainqueur ouais alors tu as
raison et je comprends et moscou ont
extrêmement serré rires je vais le faire
mais vraiment surtout l'habitude de zola
si je suis pas là pour ça
68 morts mais si j'étais toi je vais te
manquer à
bastien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on est donc réalité et gravité on est
demandé à la régie quelque chose de très
mignon c'est que quand vous avez gagné
vous avez une très belle expression
j'espère qu'ils vont la remettre regard
des aléas tête à l'aube alors c'est trop
loin vous avez la langue dehors
[Rires]
soit regarder cette séquence maudite